[Musica]
buongiorno mi chiamo roma e alessandro
sono ingegnere meccanico e ho sviluppato
il progetto che ha consentito di
modificare una maschera da snorkeling
per adattarla una maschera per la
respirazione assistita dei pazienti
affetti covi di 19 oggi sono qui per
parlarvi di innovazione e più nello
specifico di innovazione etica e perché
e quando questi due termini sono legati
tra di loro con la parola innovazione
siamo tutti portati a pensare che sia
rivolta tutto quell insieme di
innovazioni tecnologiche come
l'invenzione della ruota la scoperta
della corrente elettrica o lo sviluppo
del personal computer
in realtà il senso di innovazione è un
po più ampio perché viene definito come
tutto quell insieme di percorsi processi
e prodotti che apportino delle migliori
o dei benefici rispetto allo stato della
tecnica precedente apporto inoltre
queste innovazioni degli importanti
sviluppi per la società moderna
all'interno di questa definizione di
innovazione quindi possono rientrare
anche importanti traguardi storico
politici o alcune importanti scoperte
scientifiche come ad esempio
l'introduzione del suffragio universale
del diritto allo studio o la scoperta
della penicillina solitamente
l'innovazione e più nello specifico
l'innovazione tecnologica comporta per i
suoi fautori un importante sviluppo
importante guadagno economico piuttosto
che un importante vantaggio competitivo
sul mercato e questo è un ottima leva
per il continuo sviluppo della
tecnologia
a volte però l'etica che è quella
dottrina che si occupa di studiare il
comportamento umano di definire cosa è
giusto e cosa non lo sia
interviene in questo percorso e va a
modificare innalzando il fine ultimo
dell'innovazione dal vantaggio personale
al bene comune o bene collettivo
un esempio di quando l'etica influenza
l'innovazione se lo porta a nils bohlin
ingegnere meccanico che nel 1959
brevetta e inventa la cintura di
sicurezza per automobili a 3 punti
in quegli anni non mantenne privato
questo brevetto ma anzi lo rese pubblico
per far sì che non solo che comprasse un
automobile in quegli anni potesse
beneficiare di questa innovazione
tecnologica ma chiunque comprasse un
automobile
e stato ipotizzato che ad oggi questo
brevetto abbia salvato più di un milione
di vite ed è stato inserito dall ufficio
nazionale tedesco dei brevetti tra gli
otto migliori brevetti che hanno
maggiormente influenzato la società
civile moderna anche si innova un po
come miss bowling ha voluto creare un
progetto salva vita e mantenerlo aperto
al pubblico
il tutto è iniziato nel marzo del 2020
quindi a cavallo del primo lockdown
quando siamo stati contattati da un
ospedale della nostra città brescia che
ci chiedeva se fosse possibile replicare
un prodotto che era carente in quel
momento ovvero una valvola venturi che
serviva per portare dell'ossigeno alle
maschere respiratorie dei pazienti
noi chiaramente abbiamo accettato la
sfida provando a replicarla e fornendo
più di 100 valvole in meno di due giorni
a questo ospedale
detto così sembra un progetto un po
semplice replicare un prodotto esistente
in realtà anno scorso tante insidie
soprattutto tecniche perché chiaramente
replicare in 3d un prodotto esistente
non garantisce la stessa tenuta
geometrica e la stessa rugosità
superficiale che in quel caso erano
necessari per il corretto funzionamento
del componente ma anche qualche insidia
legale nel senso che fornire ad un
ospedale un prodotto che non è
certificato produzione medicale non è
così semplice ci si assume sempre
qualche rischio perché non avevamo
l'autorità vera e propria per poter
fornire questi dispositivi
però in periodi di emergenza si fa di
necessità virtù a seguito di questo
progetto sono stati scritti articoli di
giornale su di noi
articoli che hanno permesso al dottor
favero un ex medico in pensione di
contattarci e di venire nei nostri
uffici e presentarsi un'altra sfida
ancora più grande di quella di prima che
era quella di fornire un dispositivo che
sarebbe a breve venuto a mancare sempre
a causa della pandemia negli ospedali
per trattare i pazienti e questa era la
maschera per la terapia subintensiva
prima di accettare anche questa sfida ci
siamo seduti attorno a un tavolo e ci
siamo detti caso è andato bene il
progetto delle valvole venturi stiamo un
po cavalcando l'onda ce la sentiamo di
affrontare anche questa sfida che sembra
ancora più grande di quella di prima e
in più quando si tratta più di replicare
un prodotto esistente adattandolo
mediante la stampa 3d per salvare
qualche vita qua si tratta di creare
qualcosa di più grande qua si tratta di
modificare una maschera da snorkeling
una maschera da spiaggia
per trattare pazienti che sono a rischio
della vita
quindi è una cosa molto complessa
abbiamo accettato lo stesso la sfida
perché ci sembrava di essere in debito
verso tutti di dover dare tutto quello
che era nelle nostre capacità per
provare aiutare anche noi nella lotta
alla pandemia perché eravamo quasi in un
periodo di guerra
quindi abbiamo accettato la sfida
abbiamo provato a contattare qualche
autorità per chiedergli il permesso di
sviluppare questo dispositivo per
chiedergli possiamo applicare un
dispositivo non idoneo all'uso
biomedicale in periodi di pandemia
la risposta è stata da tutti dovete
mandarci dell'email contatteremo il
nostro responsabile vi faremo sapere a
breve però il nostro nemico principale
in quel momento era il tempo
il fine ultimo di adattare la maschera
da snorkeling per trattare i pazienti
covip era quello di tamponare l'esigenza
che avevano gli ospedali in quel momento
che era quella di non riuscire a
provvigionali dei prodotti certificati
di conseguenza il tempo era il nemico
principale abbiamo lo stesso accettato
la sfida andando anche un po
controcorrente sfidando la legge pur di
cercare di dare una mano con le nostre
capacità
ho ridisegnato un componente in un paio
d'ore che potesse collegare il
l'apertura del boccaglio della maschera
ai componenti ospedalieri inutilizzato
in tutti i più comuni ospedali che erano
i tubi di trasporto dell'ossigeno
ne abbiamo stampati 45 pezzi come
mediante le stampanti 3d e poi l'abbiamo
portata in due o tre ospedali per
testarli il primo ospedale a cui
l'abbiamo portata una maschera da
snorkeling con cui con con collegata una
valvola e ci ha detto benissimo
sembra un progetto interessante lo provo
subito su un paziente un po allarmati
metto calmino di abbiamo portato un idea
di progetto che possa essere utile in
caso testato per trattare qualche
paziente
la risposta del del medico me la ricordo
ancora bene insieme alla sua faccia che
ci ha detto guardate io ho dei pazienti
che sono in difficoltà respiratorie
molto gravi e devo decidere se provare
ad aiutarli con questa maschera
piuttosto che lasciarli senza ossigeno
voi cosa fareste io e mi titolare che
eravamo lì in quel momento
ci siamo guardati negli occhi nessuno di
due risposto che il medico ha preso è
andato a testare la maschera è tornato
dopo 15 minuti interminabili sembrava
veramente fossero due ore e all'inizio
compasso un pò veloce si è fermato e ha
detto funziona e liberamente le emozioni
hanno cominciato a prendere sopravvento
siamo corsi di nuovo il nostro ufficio e
il grosso del progetto il difficile
arriva proprio in quel momento la
validazione medica se proprio così si
può dire era solo il primo passo ora
c'era bisogno di costruire
un'infrastruttura che permettesse di
approvvigionarsi di maschere di produrre
valvole e di distribuire i dispositivi
maschere e valvole perché come ha detto
il tempo era il nostro nemico principale
noi eravamo una piccola aziendina in
quel momento eravamo solo in cinque in
ufficio e non eravamo pronti per
affrontare una sfida così grande e
soprattutto da soli
fortunatamente anche qui l'etica ha
avuto un ruolo fondamentale all'interno
del nostro progetto perché tante persone
ci hanno aiutato senza chiedere poi
nulla in cambio
quindi e dagli avvocati che ci hanno
aiutato nelle stendere un testo che
potesse dire agli ospedali
con utilizzare questo dispositivo in
periodo di pandemia in periodo di
emergenza anche se le leggi non fossero
proprio a favore di questo suo utilizzo
altri traduttori ci hanno aiutato
tradurre questo testo po in diverse
lingue
ci sono stati degli informatici che ci
hanno migliorato il sito perché non era
pronto per affrontare un accesso così
elevato di utenti e soprattutto l'aiuto
più grande al abbiamo avuto dai privati
e dai maker microsot che sono quelli che
hanno delle stampanti 3d per passione
piuttosto che professione che ci hanno
aiutato a stampare delle valvole perché
noi abbiamo pubblicato abbiamo
brevettato questo progetto per evitare
speculazioni e abbiamo chiesto e poi
liberamente a chiunque volesse aiutarci
con il sul nostro file della valvola
caricato liberamente sul sito di stampa
né il più possibile per aiutarci a
rifornire gli ospedali che ne avessero
bisogno
eravamo increduli lockdown con tutto
chiuso e in meno di due giorni hanno
ricevuti nei nostri uffici in più di
1.200 valvole con veramente i fattorini
che facevano la spola dal nostro ufficio
continuando portarci scatoloni e
veramente tantissima gente da tutta
italia ci ha aiutato spendendoci pacchi
e pacchettini alcune aziende che
addirittura spedivano 200 valvole che
avevano rimesso in moto la loro
produzione per aiutarci veramente
l'aiuto di tanti se aiutato a sviluppare
questo progetto e la fortuna di aver
sfruttato la tecnologia di stampa 3d per
la produzione di queste valvole
tecnologia che non è proprio la
tecnologia prescelta per produzione in
grandi lotti ma la fortuna di avere
sfruttato questa tecnologia è stata la
capillarizzazione della produzione
perché perché se noi avessimo potuto
anche eventualmente produrre tutto
questo elevato numero di valvole non
saremo poi stati agevolati nella
spedizione attorno a tutto il mondo
perché poi ricordiamo che in tutto il
mondo sono state utilizzate più di 100
mila di queste valvole quindi anche la
spedizione in portogallo in brasile in
cina è veramente sarebbe stata molto
difficoltosa invece caricando il file
online sul nostro sito
in meno di tre ore siamo stati in grado
di avere una produzione in brasile in
australia in cina in nuova zelanda cosa
che neanche con i migliori spedizionieri
saremmo stati in grado di spedire quindi
con l'aiuto di tanti siamo riusciti a
fare il bene di molti
dopo questo progetto sono stati scritti
diversi articoli di giornale su di noi
anche dalle testate più importanti del
mondo quindi a partire dal new york
times alla bbc ai giornali nazionali con
reti da sera giornali e asiatici di
giornali che non riuscivo neanche a
leggere in arabo quindi ma anche perché
è stato preso come simbolo di speranza
di possibilità di chiunque di fare
qualcosa per gli altri
abbiamo ricevuto alcuni premi nazionali
il mio titolare ha addirittura ricevuto
il titolo di cavaliere al merito del
presidente repubblica avevamo ricevuto
premi internazionali come ad esempio il
mother teresa world for social justice
twenty twenty
e questa cosa ci ha riempito veramente
di gioia perché abbiamo visto come il
nostro lavoro
da piccola azienda è riuscito a
diventare un lavoro enorme aiutare tante
persone ma la cosa che veramente sabato
più piacere sono le cose piccole quelle
più dirette più vere come leggere un
biglietto scritto da un bambino in una
scatola di valvole che diceva queste
sono le valvole che ha stampato il mio
papà per aiutarvi a salvare delle vite
cos'è che toccanti come una mail di un
medico in brasile che ha detto qua nel
mio ospedale avete salvato 110 vite
complimenti ragazzi cioè cose veramente
che ci hanno toccato molto da questo
progetto non ci siamo arricchiti quasi
per niente è economicamente perché
invece come persone possiamo veramente
dirsi molto più ricchi abbiamo
guadagnato molto di più di quanto
abbiamo dato agli altri e questo è
veramente il senso di innovazione etica
quello fatto per gli altri in cui ti
ritorna veramente molto di più di quanto
hai dato
grazie a tutti